too
well well well
welcome back everybody
the moment you've all been waiting for
here
on the frenemy set
one of the biggest podcasts in the world
you know what's crazy dan is that um
on the top podcast spot like we're
number 12 in in the united states
but frenemies is still on the top chart
like 44 something in the top 100 and we
have not made a new episode of frenemies
in over a year
[Music]
so i'm just trying to illustrate what a
cultural phenomenon this show was
and i'm so excited
okay there's someone you've all been
missing
uh they've got long blonde hair
they ruined my life
and frankly uh they disgust me
well welcoming uh back to the show
oliver tree
[Applause]
welcome man it's really nice to have you
here you know
just like old times it's crazy man
a lot's changed yeah
looks like you uh you haven't really
been taking care of yourself
oh
okay i thought we were gonna be cool
i'm trying i just wanted to see how are
you and how are my god
i just can we just edit that out it's
like passive aggressive should we start
over
no i don't have time for starting over
and stuff just like i just want to ask
yeah how are my godsons
uh i don't know who are your godsons
michael and trevor
who are they
your kids my god
theodore and bruce who are not your
children or no they're god
children for the record grandchildren or
your god children for the record that
was not something we acknowledged ever
well i think that's to be debated i
remember in episode 136 when i first
came to the show you and gila both
agreed that i would be godfather i don't
know trevor
that's a fact
all right
so we can look and find that clip uh
episode 136 was about pewdiepie's
wedding you were not in that episode you
literally made it maybe it was 137 like
everything in your life is a lie what
are you talking about dude you know
exactly what i'm talking about
everything's a lot your hair is alive
this outfit's alive you're a fake cowboy
bro why do you come on here and act like
all right this is really off to a rough
start i apologize well you can't passive
aggressive i came in thinking that we
could keep this cordial and now you're
acting like an idiot
just chill let's start over let's just
start should i walk off and we try this
one more time yeah yeah yeah
welcome guys introducing the long blonde
haired
stupid-ass
piece of [ __ ] loser phony ass [ __ ] fat
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
uh oliver tree everybody all right
terrible music did i did i uh mention
terrible music
i like it how we doing today good to see
you brother
good to see you man let's embrace you
can bring it into your brother don't
touch the hair don't touch the hair
stop stop don't touch it don't just stay
here all right let's just let's just
talk okay let's get this over with let's
get it over with this
episode uh
thank you
sponsored by hellofresh thank you to
hello wait teddy fresh
also i wanted to say teddy fresh because
i know you're going to be plugging your
your [ __ ] the whole episode with like
tours and tickets and stuff
so i just want to get my plugin first
okay.com this shirt by the way is a
fresh release from teddyface.com that is
one of the ugliest shirts i've ever seen
okay well watch your mouth because this
is ela's design
okay and you don't want to get in
trouble i love gila but this might be
the ugliest shirt that teddy fresh has
to do let's not touch you let's not
touch me okay let's not do that it's not
getting each other's space
actually i already messed my hair up
well the the green screen is king out
the green but you can see how beautiful
it is
there's no green dude are you colorblind
that's a green leaves dude
stop
and then there's this shirt
and there's also [ __ ]
there's also a dress
that you could get this in right i'm not
gonna click it
i'm going to be considerate of your time
unlike i'm sure when you plug your [ __ ]
it's going to take like 30 minutes but
if you guys are into any clothing going
on
that is some of your guys worst designs
yet
all right
so anyway also i just want to introduce
um olivia's grandma is visiting in case
you guys see
just so you guys
aren't wondering who that is grandma i'm
sorry wha what was uh
what what's your name is she allowed to
talk to the mic yeah yeah of course wait
wait i literally know this woman
tree is that you
oh my god you look beautiful wait how do
you know what are you talking about we
worked together she was in my music
video for swinging a miss
oh my god how are you
i'm sorry no way i knew that that is
crazy
i knew that you were an actress i didn't
know that you were you were in his music
video
that's great uh-huh wait so what's your
name treat treat okay can i come give
you a hug oh oh my god i did my hair
just like just like yours i'm so excited
yeah so okay i guess
she was in the music video wait i'm
sorry what's so weird about that
well she didn't tell me first of all
this is crazy this is a warm embrace
oliver
and treat okay oh my god all right guys
all right
oliver
oliver treat
hey it's so embarrassing
no no no don't play that music stop stop
stop guys guys guys grandma grandma
oh my god grandma sit down please
can we
you edit that far down i don't know
what's happening
you gotta control your grammar or
something dude because i have no clue
here or what
no it's
um all right have a seat oliver i have
some questions
what the [ __ ]
bro we did a video together
yeah but you guys hugged for like two
minutes
did you pop a woody bro stop don't
embarrass me stop
don't embarrass me oh i'm sorry
well i don't know the way they are i'm
sorry i'm sorry graeme retreat wait
what's the music video guys we're in let
me watch it it's called swinging a miss
and i'm surprised you haven't seen any
of my videos
is it the one that i'm thinking of where
you're
you're making out with
no yeah wow or may not that's a little
bit yeah i didn't know that was olivia's
grandmother livi did you know that
no i'm literally i'm confronting her
right now why didn't you tell me that's
insane okay you knew that he was going
to be in the studio today okay so a
couple of things if you want to grow up
and be like me
then don't tell everybody your business
i
mean that's pretty awesome that's good
advice really good advice
also i want to say this welcome back
olivia the only good part of this shitty
ass podcast is this her it is so nice to
finally meet you it is so nice to meet
you a huge fan far from the tree
or the apple doesn't fall far from the
treat
i like it i like it a lot who the hell
that's good wait is this you dude you're
gonna just jump around i don't wanna
watch the whole thing oh no wait just
start it over no i don't wanna watch it
right now i just wanna see the this part
is this you chris no no no i come in
later
dude you're ruining the whole video
graphic
can we even show that on youtube i don't
know it's just kissing maybe blur it
or just grab a treat
all right dude here are you gonna watch
the video or not keep going no keep
going
is this it
yeah
so
that's me and her
it's so crazy no you're not that's not
true yes it is no it's not go back
yeah i need to go back hold on
yeah i don't know if you're here
[Music]
so wait oh that's you right here yep
oh my god
grandma
dude you guys made out
multiple times i mean we had to do the
take like 32 times was it 32 or 33
uh
i was hoping for 33 i think we had to
cut at 32 because you were running
long
literally i'm a treatise grandma
oh my god come on grandma is thirsty for
all dude your grandma's kind of wild
she's very what's up grandma treat how
you doing how you doing no no no no no
no no stop whoa
whoa
well here let's watch it let's not look
away from the beginning dude no i don't
want to watch it please is that you guys
can we get a redo on that
oh my god
grandma i'm going to throw you out of
the studio
that is incredible
he's gonna pick you up i told you this
was a bad idea olivia let me play
slow-mo guys
do we have any reading glasses for him
or something no it's it's being covered
by i have glasses
it's being covered by the camera it's
not an eyesight thing okay have you
watched this back and beat off be honest
stop
i'm not gonna say
oliver tell me honestly how many times
have you watched that part of the video
that's what i that's literally the best
part when i was in the editing bay
editing this video i literally just had
that on a loop for two hours i'm not
going to say what i did
but i will say that is the best part of
the entire video and that
chef's kiss
um
i think i'm gonna vomit yeah i'm not
interested in what either of you have to
say all right can you guys just keep it
together for the show here uh let's
watch this in slow motion though oliver
or i mean olivia look away
yeah
is that your dentures yep
oh my god oh my god oh my god
that is vulgar shame on you both
come on ethan
okay can we
play it one more time no
wow that's such a crazy coincidence i
know that seems so nice to see you
i hope you'll stick around afterwards oh
i hope so too no um
i texted my mom i think you're being put
in a home after this grandma tree
don't worry she's being picked up okay
good yeah
anyway well that's kind of nuts i'm
really not even sure how to move on
after that but uh do we need to you
won't just wrap it up here i think so
and done a high note i think i got what
i needed that's something to do yeah
he's gotta wrap it up let's make this
you know what i'm saying i don't think
we need to waste too much time honda
mana's penis is what i'm saying thank
you you gotta wrap it up all right all
right yep you guys are michael well you
probably don't need to wrap it up i mean
are you can i ask you a question grandma
treat
sure are you still um
oh yeah are you still uh ovulating
jesus that train pulled out of the
station a long time ago that's kind of a
plus that's a big place oh yeah
i'm not going to make any little trees
any sprouts
and grametry are you still
are you still sexually active
that is yeah that's she i will have you
know that i can put my ankles behind my
neck hey grandma that's enough like that
is enough is that right
i'm not kidding wait i thought when you
hit menopause
sorry sorry olivia should i stop
can you just take that part out maybe
just but i just have one more question
it's a live show guys i thought when you
hit menopause that you lose your sex
drive is that not true that's not true
oh
that is not true that is absolutely not
true oh okay uh for me menopause means
that i just pause from certain men
okay
and i
pick my my men more wisely and usually
they're younger
you're in the clear
dude you can nut inside of her no no no
no no no
that's crazy bro
that's crazy thing oh man this is fun i
like this
this is what we call an edumacation i'm
red i'm red i'm so sorry maybe we should
roll some of that back
it's a live show my friend
all right let's talk about your tour
let's talk about it uh last time olive
tree music right there
there was
miscommunication ethan tweeted out olive
trees
oh no he just tweeted out olivetree.com
here it is and that is not the correct
site that is actually a bible app
download free bible app a lot of people
were downloading bibles and buying
bibles hard copies that get sent to your
door within 24 hours which is actually a
pretty good deal uh but that is not the
correct site there's actually a site
that is oliver tree music okay
not olive tree it's with the
r and yeah it's a big deal it's my
laptop what is this okay that's
olivertree.com i couldn't afford the
domain name stop
well they bought it wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait sell it to me
for 40 grand i don't have any
olivertree.com and then here's all of
bubble study that is not the correct
site it's oliver tree music sure it's
not your website that is not my website
i wish it was i would definitely love
that hold on i'm on olivertree.com if
anybody wants to make a donation of 40
000 maybe we can do like a gofundme that
what they wanted for real yeah they
wanted 40 grand
and i just could swing that no i don't i
don't what about the label or something
nobody what if i buy it and then i can
hold it over your head forever i'll
leave it would you do that for me i
would lease it to you okay thousands a
month
yeah
no no no no
okay
i would love to i would love to get the
real proper site
but for now we have oliver tree music
and i'm doing my last final tour ever
this is the last one so if you want to
see me perform this is it and there is a
lot of teddy fresh in that crowd it is
where you're going to find potentially
your new best friend or
dare i say your husband or wife or
whomever but this is going to be where a
lot of the fupa troopers are going to be
hanging and um it's a big deal we're
going across america for one last time
we're also going to be hitting australia
and uh it's pretty exciting man so this
is where you buy tickets yes sir june
17th that's right around the corner
where is that that's july 17th oh that
says june oh yeah that's amazing do you
even know where you
the [ __ ] you don't even know when you're
playing i don't know i play shows every
week okay don't forget
remember what's the lemonade
lyrical lemonade
it's a hip-hop festival so so why are
you there well i do a little hippity-hop
no you don't yes i do do freestyle for
me
i i don't want to do it on the spot
that's too much pressure
all right well there you have it if you
guys want to go waste your money on this
[ __ ]
i'll retrieve you
i'll just say this if you guys get a
chance this is going to be the greatest
show that ever made let's just put it
this way no let's put it this way if you
want to see some of the greatest
storytelling some of the greatest
scooter stunts performance art comedy
motivational speaking belly dancing we
got it all we're doing it all wwf
wrestling and ethan if you come to one
of these shows i'm not i will fight you
on stage okay good i'm not and i will
take you like i took down yo
to go see oliver it costs 95 bucks bro
that's a festival and i'm playing with
my homie post malone oh he's there yeah
headlining he is yeah yeah you're
probably not gonna be able to get in to
see him uh that he's the headline
where's your name on this well
technically wait where's your name on
this in the tiny little on i have my own
little spot it's um playing a few songs
and some scooter tricks
in the bottom right corner
oh you got it oh that's kind of dope i
got my own
because i'm not really part of the bill
you know kind of doing my own thing oh
that's dope though that's better than
like one of these losers on the bottom
okay that's not cool dude
i'm just show some respect these guys
are coming up this is the future hey
little tracy's going to be there
your buddy well ethan yeah a little
trait of the guy i've beef with on
twitter i thought you guys were tight i
listen if you have 95 bucks you can go
see oliver tree
or you can buy some teddyfresh.com
one last forever
that's a festival that's not my actual
tour okay so how much is a ticket to
your tour i don't know not exactly sure
yeah right like you know but it's a hell
of a deal whatever you're getting you're
gonna get tenfold in return from this
experience i'm telling you this is the
greatest show of all time we play
everything from rock music to pop music
to hippie hoppity we've got literally
dance music country music the works man
there's something there for everyone
even a guy like you
let's see in australia
find tickets
don't look at the australia the dollar
is way off in australia the number is
not going to be correct i can convert it
do the us tour did the one we're
actually promoting here
no the the ones coming up is in
australia
no
tour across america is the big deal man
it's my last shows ever in my home it
says you're in australia till what
[ __ ]
you're in australia new zealand san
diego okay yeah that's august 4th okay a
very important date
i have to say this i have a very special
announcement
i am playing august 4th in san diego at
petco park
with my first ever festival
i haven't announced all the names that
are playing with me yet but check this
out
so let's see i have a little gift for
you ethan general admission 50 bucks
yeah you could it's a festival dude the
other festival was ninety dollars well
that check this out yeah i am announcing
this for the first time i'm just saying
you could get a shirt i'm just saying
one shirt or the best moment of your
entire life where you find your
husband's shirt
significant other you can wear it daily
you can enjoy it yeah that's where you
go
i really want to wear it oh yeah let me
go let me go to a festival and spend ten
dollars for a [ __ ] water bro come on
please i know you're gonna this is not
just any festival this is the greatest
festival ever i know how this [ __ ] works
you go oh it's only 50 bucks to get in
yeah and we don't have fountains and you
have to pay us 10 for dasani you are a
salty old bastard
show me what you have i have a gift from
me to you
announcing my first ever festival and my
last ever discussion
we heard you said that like 20 times
just show the [ __ ] can i get a drum roll
no
no
let me get a drum roll no
no ladies and gentlemen the greatest
that's it i said that that's not even a
drum roll they're my guys he pays me i'm
sorry oliver can you hit me with
something a little harder get playing
with some goofy ass like
please
this is a big announcement dude i'm
doing it on your shitty show you should
be so [ __ ] lucky
yeah i should be lucky for my fans to go
to your [ __ ] dumbass yeah here you go
ladies and gentlemen
the greatest festival
an entertainment experience of all time
oliver tree presents
can you play some clowns stop like
honking like when they honk their nose
yeah yeah yeah yeah add that to the
music add that to the music wait hold on
with the announcement
and then and then honk as he's
presenting ladies and gentlemen the
where's the music
the greatest entertainment experience
can we just keep it going
can we not do the honks
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i present you
oliver trees
fire festival oh no that's a bad name
that is a horrible name hold this up
this is a bad bad idea this is the
greatest festival of all time
[Music]
well you know about the fire festival
with the why what
there was like a big scam and
ja rule
and the scam guy
i'm not familiar oh also okay well
anyway i'm sure it'll be great this is
fire festival and i will say this
yeah fire festival
what the [ __ ] he scammed investors out
of 26 million that's not related to you
is it no this is nothing to do with me
that's spelled with a y dude mine's
f-i-r-e that's what i said i said with
the y okay so anyway i'm sure it'll be
really good it's gonna be [ __ ] epic
it's not just gonna be really good and i
want you to be there i want you to come
on stage and fight me like a [ __ ] man
in san diego yeah san diego it's a
little far don't you think no i don't
think it's literally a two-hour drive
and it's my last show ever
okay maybe part of my last tour you
should come will you come but i'm just
saying okay okay first
tickets
entire crew to the last [ __ ] show i
played at the shrine a sold-out show
that was literally jam-packed with
people and this [ __ ] dude he gets 12
tickets on the guest list where the [ __ ]
were you dude you didn't show up go
ahead and explain what happened
this is
oh can i get in this second thing i was
like yeah you're sorted you're good i
got you all 12. which is absurd bro a
sold-out show yeah it's [ __ ]
impossible those 12 spots the whole crew
was invited and nobody [ __ ] showed up
no but dan say what happened
dan show the receipts
show go show the receipts because i
go ahead dan he'll know yeah show the
receipts he'll show he [ __ ] up what's
that face dan
i just can't believe what i'm being told
right now by oliver well he did look at
our [ __ ] text messages you asked me i
said yeah you're good and then you text
me the next day i'm like did you come
and you're like no oh we didn't think we
could come i was like bro
tell your side of the story tell tell
what happened
okay we gave you the names
and we were waiting for confirmation and
we never heard
that confirmation let him talk gave you
confirmation show your text messages
well dude you're like fun [ __ ]
believable i was texting you and you
weren't answering stop with the [ __ ]
whistles dude it's a horn it's a horn
dumbass not cool
go ahead dan tell your side i mean that
was it
that was it yeah you [ __ ] up big time
by not getting a response but not
getting information
i'm literally it's my show i've told
ethan he's good and what happened
i was texting oh you i was like
i told you all these details you ghosted
me i didn't ghost you and also i was
playing a show dude i wasn't texting
people were flying in from other [ __ ]
countries it was a big deal it was a
mystery you weren't there you're a
horrible friend no listen we are a
horrible friend just admit that
i wanted you you said you would be there
so now if you want to make this right
you'll come to san diego okay i'll
i'll do my fire fest i'll do my i'll let
you come on stage and you and i can hash
it out man-to-man is that a promise it's
i'll have to see what's the actual date
that's a promise it's august 4th i'm
going to have to park i'm going to have
to the padres play baseball games this
is a [ __ ] festival i want you there
i'm going to have to check my calendar
you're going to come but i'm going to
try my this is a chance for you guys to
meet ethan clown no no don't buy tickets
don't buy tickets for that reason hey
can i ask something yes oh what's up
treat
like i made out with you 32 times and i
wasn't on your guest list well you
didn't ask i thought you hated the music
i love your music wow well just so you
know you have free tickets for life and
ethan only has a free ticket for one
show so anytime you want to come to an
oliver tree concert treat it would be my
honor can treat come on stage treat can
come on stage of course
we can share can i come on stage of
course we can share this i can literally
say intimate moment
i don't think she's allowed to come on
stage that'd be vulgar
and there's no kids sick mine you know
that
you're the one that was [ __ ]
basically bro i gave my friend a hug and
basically penetrated her back there
not yet
she's oh my god
unbelievable
what is so [ __ ] funny
all right whatever so fire festival i
will actually i will try to make it and
next week i'm announcing the names who
are playing and opening up and it's
going to be [ __ ] crazy and if you're
not there you're the worst one of the
day again what's the date august 4th
petco party lina do we have anything on
that day
oh lena says we're busy that day
that's crazy yeah no oh you're actually
super busy on that day
that's crazy actually that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] she just checked my calendar
what do you do exactly
what's on that day lena
um you have a few appointments and then
appointments what kind of appointments
um that's that's private i can't you can
tell them it's okay
well you have some doctor's appointments
we can move that around dude
i'll try there was one there we couldn't
move right lena which one was that
what was that
which appointment can't we move yeah
there's one there we can't move right
lina well what time is your your event
at
what time's your event start
what time is your doctor appointment
what times your events start bro it
starts at a reasonable hour just give me
an idea probably like you know it's a
festival probably around four i'm busy
again
but i'm not going on until about 10 or
11 is that right yeah you got a doctor's
appointment at midnight i'm gonna try
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try to make it
we can have fun yeah no you're gonna
make it you're gonna do with this
[ __ ] day and you're gonna finally
make good on the promise of me and the
whole crew coming here it's going to be
our first and last festival this is a
big deal to ask you do you turn up at
your shows bro we get wild bro
and i actually did some [ __ ] ethan
klein chants some of my shows and some
footage we could probably find of that
stop
stop that's not [ __ ] cool okay
uh but yeah it's going to be crazy as my
last tour ever we're going across
america one last ride it's gonna be fun
i actually i think i think we could all
go do that that'd be fun yeah maybe we
could get a score bus so you can get us
12 tickets i'll get you whatever you
want and treat you definitely need to be
there can i just go on the bus with you
ethan
uh that's up ask olivia about that um if
you do that i'm staying home
olivia i want to talk about what i'm not
if you do that i'm going to stay home i
think i can't handle that honey it would
be so much fun to do a grandma
granddaughter concert together
it would be the perfect place to do it
there is no better place than an oliver
tree concert for a grandmother
granddaughter experience and i want to
say if you're going to the show bring
your grandma yo real quick i need to
[ __ ] ethan klein
[ __ ] ethan cry
why'd you do that
why'd you do that dude that's not cool
they did it i didn't even have to ask
you literally started that chant
what did i do to you that's [ __ ] up
and by the way do not bring your grandma
to a oliver tree shop there's a good
chance he's going to [ __ ] her he's right
you know why
that's competition for me
dude she's dancing
treat you're going to be there i'll take
care of you don't worry promise i
promise all right let's move on okay
yeah
please
um
but no i will try to be there that
sounds no no you will be there
yeah and your fans will have a chance to
meet you like a meet and greet type
situation
should i get a hotel out there i'd say
so yeah spend the night yeah we'll have
a big party afterwards maybe some
exclusive
you know give away a ticket for some
fans to hang out with us who knows
are you where you stay in the motel six
do they have a presidential suite there
that's not [ __ ] cool i didn't know
they had presidential suites at like the
[ __ ]
holiday inn
that's actually not a bad one motel 6.
all right dude let's just keep moving
here this is going extremely all right
yada yada um
you should we watch a music video yeah
i'd love to show the actual music video
that i had
the sweetheart known as treat
oh you have called a swing and a miss
and it's probably the greatest music
video of all times and yes it was age
restricted and i had my lawyer jeremiah
it's kind of graphic is it kissing so we
have to we actually have no no you'll be
fine i got it on age restricted well i
don't have but the thing is it really
screwed me it screwed me yeah that's in
the good note we definitely should just
blur it no you don't have to blur
anything well if you want to watch the
whole video you can go see it on my
channel that has a lot more followers
than the h3 channel i know that they're
losing followers like flies
right how many did you lose in the last
month
i know that you hit three million right
and then it went under like
260. we're the two point h 2.9 yeah no i
don't think you're even there anymore i
think it dropped down to like 260 if
last time i checked at least how'd your
new album do by the way said it's
amazing really yeah i mean some of the
best numbers yet
that's crazy i didn't see it on any of
the charts it was on the charts
oh was it on like alternative [ __ ]
cowboy [ __ ] number one
uh it's technically the alternative
the alternative yeah yeah big stiff
competition
you and uh kid rock's uh great grandson
all right
let's keep moving okay did you want to
talk about hanging out with post malone
i see all right i want to say this first
of all your fans should be thanking me
for reconnecting this [ __ ] bozo with
post malone
so
you guys i don't know if you guys saw
the picture here i'll pull it up we were
hanging out with post malone that is
well technically i was hanging out with
post malone and i let you come along
like the annoying little cousin okay let
me just say what happened so let me pull
this picture up because they we were
there with brittany broski and post it
was awesome uh really a lot of fun
and
oliver tree oh bobby's here
bobby would you shut the [ __ ] up
he came he actually came
we're trying to work here
are you really talking out loud and
recording i mean what a [ __ ]
degenerate would someone shut that
[ __ ] guy up
bobby lee came in here just talking full
volume you bet you've been in showbiz
how long bobby and you've talked full
volume during a recording
30 years this guy doesn't know how to
close set control his volume
unbelievable
so this basically the story is that um
the story is ethan is a [ __ ] clout
chaser taking pictures every chance he
can't dude
let it be a magical moment it doesn't
need all the video footage all the click
bait stuff did you post that [ __ ] didn't
you retweet it no i didn't retweeting
yes you did
anyway listen so oliver's like yo i took
i took credit for reuniting you bro the
thing is he texted me before you even
said that it doesn't matter because he
didn't invite you to his [ __ ] event
and i messaged you and i was like hey do
you hear posellon's having an album
really invited me and i asked you no he
did not and i asked you i said do you
hear about this you're like no and then
i was like well would you like to come i
can ask his a r who invited me on behalf
of post to invite you i remember and
then
what happened i remember that he texted
me before that yeah but he didn't do
[ __ ] for you to get into this event he
didn't want you there and i was able to
give you my plus two spot for you and
gila i don't think that's what happened
that's what happened
and who gets in this too
that's not even a real problem that's a
real thing and then the other thing that
happened was i was able to get you the
address to go hang out with post after
and what happened post malone had us
sign ndas
the funniest part was he only made one
person sign it he was like i've got all
these ndas for you guys to sign and then
they literally just had ethan sign it
and that's not true yes that is
because you're such a friend everybody
knows you can't trust this [ __ ] guy
you're such a liar bro
they made everyone sign yeah that's what
dude they're like everyone needs to sign
these and then they're like ethan we'll
start with you dude
you were the one taking pictures in his
bathroom and [ __ ] and taking little
pictures of him he made that up he just
made that no they literally created the
nda you were in there doing video
recordings and taking photos
and you were like i saw you even creep
in his backyard trying to get catch
pictures of his family and [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up dude
that's [ __ ] up
this is what how dare you okay we get
there and they give us ndas to sign and
then literally they're like everyone
should sign these and then ethan is
first like ethan would you please sign
this ethan takes the picture he signs
the thing and then he goes into the back
and then literally ethan's gone it's
just me and a few other people a handful
of very close friends which obviously
ethan is not and what happened was
i look at him like do we actually have
to sign this he said no it was literally
just for ethan that's
bro okay what's the fact well if that's
true they should have made you sign one
because you were the one peeping tom and
his f because we were out back in like
the
in like the guests you're supposed to
talk about anything bro
that's what nda is i can talk about it
but you cannot and then he was creeping
around looking and with his [ __ ]
phone taking pictures you're living in a
[ __ ] fantasy you live in a [ __ ]
delusion you got a new family and you're
trying to get pictures of their babies
i don't even take a single picture by
the way film a [ __ ] story this guy's
telling me by the way look where i is
beyonce and just chill his fiancee has
never been shown his baby's never been
shown he wants privacy you're not
supposed to talk about that
and you [ __ ] were trying to take
pictures how dare you show me
one [ __ ] picture i took you probably
just jerk off with them at home
i'm just disgusting i'm about to [ __ ]
walk right now
you're unbelievable dude well i have
bobby lee here who can step in for you
he's more interesting
he is a lot more interesting than you
you're [ __ ] annoying in your stupid
[ __ ] dude
all right let's keep moving this is
going way too [ __ ] slow um but yes
you guys can thank me for bringing him
and his old friend post malone back
together yes can i get a round of
applause thank you
why are you guys clapping he's lying
i was texting me before oh oh [ __ ] you
want to watch your dumb ass music video
swinging and miss where you make up
our video together our collaboration
absolutely this is where you made out
with olivia's grandma bro i didn't know
it was olivia's grandmother at the time
all right let's watch
can we turn it up dude i feel like no
one can hear it can we crank it
everybody's thinking about all the
things they're missing out
wasting time looking back
[Music]
acting like they live it up when it's
really just a front
how funny is that
if you wait i'll wait
i'll call you and
[Music]
you're missing the best part
ethan
you're missing the best part
[Music]
were you able to get inside the gate or
did you park on the street
do you know if he parked inside
oh he parked on the street
can you get it bro are you watching the
[ __ ] video or wait hold on something
urgent came up nothing urgent stop stop
bro stop
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] phone
bro i swear to [ __ ] god you're
missing the best part
you're gonna break my
[ __ ] if this is
[Music]
you missed the whole [ __ ] video dude
the best [ __ ] part
is did bobby leave
bobby left
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] my hair up
dude all right you didn't even watch any
of the [ __ ] why would i watch it dude
i was just trying to text my wife and
see what was for dinner
why do you have such a panic attack
it's not cool
i spent so much time and money dude that
street right there
where'd you put my phone doesn't matter
sit the [ __ ] down
god damn it ethan
don't ge i told you not to give him the
[ __ ] phone
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro what do you want they're watching
the video you're not they're okay if
they're at home they can watch [ __ ]
parts what do i have to watch this is
what you want right you just want to use
my fans to show them your [ __ ]
dumbbells it's olivia's grandmother i
think they want to see this okay they
already saw it get watch i don't know
what the [ __ ] go to youtube and watch it
stop bro i swear to god
i swear to god don't touch my phone
again bro what the [ __ ] phone watch
what happens you didn't even see the
video watch what happens they got a
[ __ ] dick
you're a [ __ ] dick watch what happens
bro
what you fell on the ground i didn't
even flinch right there you flinched a
little you think you're so [ __ ] tough
i just want to make sure did bobby bobby
left dude
he [ __ ] dipped
stop can we play the video again can you
make sure he gets in the gate dan dude
he was here what do you mean
he had to park on the street i don't
give a [ __ ] it's being handled okay good
we're good all right you want to watch
freaks and geeks
bro this one also got age restricted
but my lawyer jeremiah jeffrey was able
to reverse the decision
you know you can appeal it
and most of the time they won't but this
one i think
the little guy scared people are you
gonna watch this one or not weirdo i'm a
freak
bobby help me
[Music]
about it all right don't yell in my ear
stop
eating my glasses
whether you like it or not i'm a slacker
[Music]
[Music]
dude
are you on
you broke my one [ __ ] pair of glasses
why would you do that
stop stop
[ __ ] calm down don't pull my hair
calm down then i'm calm all right
stop oh i was gonna pull the hairs
that's the trick you broke my [ __ ]
glasses
thanks why would you do that
look at my glasses nobody cares
[Applause]
god what you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you my
glasses listen we'll pay for the glasses
or something no we're not another pair
no or not yeah we'll make them shut up
dude those are made of plastic
performances this weekend dude you can
get those on al kazam for
two cents glasses are [ __ ] thousand
grand
oliver did did you get hurt yes i did oh
no bobby lee pulled my [ __ ] hair like
a [ __ ] punk
well i'll take care of that
thank you now's not the time grandma
her name is treat
just chill treat
hold hold back
it's unbelievable you [ __ ] these
things up dude why
you know what dude
this is just
why do you ruin everything
i'm trying to watch your music video
and you take it way too [ __ ] far you
take it too you start throwing punches
you start being distracted you have like
my art my life's work are you in therapy
like genuine question genuine question
no
you might have unresolved issues bro you
want some unresolved i'll give you some
unresolved issues like this is not
normal to start attacking people like
this
yeah well it's not normal to have
someone spend their life making a video
and have literally the star of the
[ __ ] video treat here in attendance
just and then you start scrolling
i will i was just trying to see if it
was age restricted
yeah it was and i reversed the [ __ ]
approval process with my guy jeremiah
jeffrey
okay fine
the video got [ __ ] [ __ ] up from me
dude it's not funny it's not just cool i
was gonna play it but now i don't know
all right so what you're looking email
cowboy
what are you doing i wanna read the
comments no one can see the video i'll
go up in a sec i just want to know
people thought about it
the video cost me a quarter million
dollars dude see this person liked it so
freaking good man i don't give a [ __ ]
dude do you like it no because you won't
watch person said oliver trees art yeah
i don't care
stop
you [ __ ] up my glasses dude you're
like you know i'm in like an abusive
relationship every time you look at me i
flinch
it's actually not cool
trigger warning because you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this person says
yeah i mean they like the video dude no
one cares the video is what they want to
see
i'm just looking
stop stop don't touch my computer you
have your own computer
stop get stop
here you want to watch it no
i don't
you already ruined it
would you just chill dude
[Music]
don't worry about your phone
[Music]
don't worry about it
okay
why don't you sit the [ __ ] down
don't worry about it just sit down
can you help you find it baby
my name is oliver i'm not a b
don't look at me in the eyes and call me
av i'm not talking you dumb [ __ ]
inbred freak you kill billy ass looking
trailer stop bro i swear i'll [ __ ] your
glasses up even worse no yeah i'm gonna
pull your hair like bobby did
how [ __ ] gary that's how i
acknowledge yours your weakness
where did this go dude you're not gonna
find his phone
no give me my [ __ ] phone you [ __ ]
i don't have it stop
i don't have your phone
i said see what happens bro
i said see what the [ __ ] happens if you
touch my phone again no i'm not [ __ ]
sit the [ __ ] down
sit the [ __ ] down you little ass man
give me my phone no
give him my phone
no
i don't have your phone dude let me
search your pockets then you're not
going to find [ __ ] let me search your
pockets then
to empty your pocket i don't have
anything all right if ethan this is
getting this is getting too this is an
episode you don't need your phone
someone stole my [ __ ] phone stop with
the [ __ ] clown phone
bobby don't you [ __ ] dare come here
bobby he stole my phone give him his
[ __ ] phone dude
nope
what's up
i don't have [ __ ] i don't have it stop
stop i feel it the [ __ ] is that bro
that's my phone
i said show that you show me you dude
stop say show it to me it's my phone
stop stop
just give it to me
abby nanny give me the [ __ ]
hello
yeah ethan klein here
stupidest man in america
[Applause]
what do you want yeah oh no i don't
understand i can't understand it it's
too [ __ ] complicated for me to
understand stop
i'm gonna start looking at [ __ ]
messages
stop stop
what do you want
[ __ ] dude i said how [ __ ] teddy that
was a gift
that was a [ __ ] gift dude i said [ __ ]
around and find out you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] move the [ __ ] out of the way
dude
what why do you do this to me bobby lee
bobby you want to come on the show
instead of oliver
i'm not going until you get my phone
back
i'm not going to get my phone back
recognize this give it to me or the
show's over not
bobby you want to step in
pick it up no i i don't
i don't want to step in no yesterday
yesterday called me egg head no i said
you look like [ __ ] humpty dumpty wait
that's racist yeah yeah that has racist
undertones yeah i'll show you race
hey watch the hair
[Applause]
pick up my phone right now i'm not
picking up [ __ ] pick it up you don't
need your phone we're doing a podcast
all right let's move to the next part of
the show okay
where's my hat
shut up
you look like [ __ ] idiot with your
broken glasses you're like a [ __ ]
idiot with that stupid-ass shirt you
literally look like you have birth
defect bro
but you did before you even put those on
no offense to people with birth defects
all right let's just wrap this up
i'm bleeding
let me see
my finger i got cut dude yeah cause you
broke a [ __ ] glass you forced me to
do it i didn't force you to do [ __ ] dude
i need first aid can we get a close-up
on this [ __ ] thing dan clean that up
i need first aid
you don't need [ __ ] let me see the cut
i'm bleeding
why would you break a glass object on
your friend you are you're not my friend
i was your friend you're not my [ __ ]
friend put you on you're bro you called
bobby lee an egghead no i didn't i said
humpty dumpty dude how many was white
what was humpty dumpty
exactly you look like humpty dumpty
i need first aid guys
it's not that serious he does not need
first aid
you broke it you did that to yourself
you broke a glass object you made me
dude you pushed me to that
i need to get him a band-aid get him a
band-aid everyone stop the show
unfucking believable this is literally
the worst podcast episode ever filmed
i need first stage here can you give me
first aid right here olivia you need the
band-aid i got him a band-aid i need my
wound treated do you have glass in it i
don't think so
i think it just got shh i think it just
got
a little bit cut he bruises like a
banana look at all his bruises go ahead
stop
what the [ __ ] dude i swear to god i'm
gonna punch you right in your dumb
[ __ ] glasses you broke them already
dude why would you break a glass object
friend tell me now i want you to ask me
that's i want to do hard you're not my
friend we're always trying to kill you i
put you on dude i connected you with
post malone this is how you repay me
it's the last time i ever do anything
for you okay i just let me treat this
wound okay just shut the [ __ ] up oh you
need a band-aid you need an ambulance
somebody call this guy a [ __ ]
ambulance
dan no one's coming you got a wambulan
tunnel
[ __ ] unbelievable
you are down bad you're literally
stealing or from keep down man i'm on
the worst podcast
all right let's move on i got my first
aid
done unbelievable dude
all right well we watched both your
music videos no we didn't watch [ __ ]
yeah let's play him back
absolutely not
can you cut out the part where we talked
about his festival for like 30 minutes
stop
we can cut it and post though we can cut
it in post we're not doing that
oh i should do an ad now no we're not
doing an ad
how long we've been going over 30
minutes i have to thank our ad
i don't want to do any ads this time we
did two minutes just sit and shut the
[ __ ] up you sit down and you shut the
[ __ ] up i have one ad do you oh look at
that he's got one ad now why because
everyone dropped him you used to do like
20 ads
what happened to you you're down bad at
least i make him i'm not stealing
people's phone the [ __ ] bro so what
we can actually have a productive
podcast here so you could sell it on
ebay oh yeah where do you where'd you
sleep last night your friend's couch
literally shut up literally that's where
you sleep might even make it carlton if
you really want to know no you didn't
yes i did
all right let me do this thank you stop
i really have to do this okay
thank you to hellofresh
hellofresh
you get fresh farm pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
can you read that part
it says yeah if you want tickets to the
greatest show of all time go to oliver
tree music forward
thank you
as guys uh follow fresh rules teddy
fresh sucks hello fresh they deliver
pre-portioned ingredients it's great
it's yummy it's healthy throw some throw
up some picks
it's delicious look at that gets
delivered to your house in pre-portioned
packs they tell you exactly how to cook
it it's nutritious it's delicious it's
balanced they say it's even cheaper than
the grocery store because you don't have
to buy a shitload of groceries
well that's what they say because you
don't have to buy a shitload of
groceries
everyone in the super trooper army
loves hello fresh
hello fresh listen to this oliver you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
fresh is 72 cheaper than dining at a
restaurant and it's even cheaper than
grocery shopping that's money back in
your pocket you dumb [ __ ]
look at that burrito and tell me that
doesn't look delicious all right that
does look pretty good
there you go you have one for me it's
your resistance i think you won do you
have one for me yeah guess what's in
that burrito what's in that burrito
these [ __ ] nuts
i didn't even say d you can't set
yourself up for a decent i just did okay
just no it's not that funny you did i
hear people laughing over here there's
ap dan even olivia was laughing she was
cracking up yeah anyway here laughing
anyway uh so so discover d discover
these nuts even love was laughing i
could sit here oh [ __ ] he's laughing at
my job yeah yeah sure for sure did you
like to discover these nuts love yeah
that was [ __ ] sick bro originally oh
[ __ ] you love
the hellofresh newest menu includes
mediterranean recipes that are filled
with fresh food and veggies and nuts
these nuts in your mouth [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
let's go these nuts olive oil and fiber
packed whole these nuts packed with
whole grain and nourishing balance dude
knob it right now
where was the drum roll when i wanted
one can you give it to him after that
heinous joke that i already said go to
hellofresh.com afterdark16 and use the
code after dark 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts
that's
uh hellofresh.com after dark 16 use code
after dark 16.
america's number one meal kit hello
[Music]
fresh dan's still cleaning up the glass
hurry up dan we're trying to get this
show on the road are we done with the
ads oh wait that's right there's only
one ad because you lost all your
sponsors from getting canceled three
times a day do you need this yeah i do
for your tears
what for my cowboy tears out now
available everywhere
i got some ads for you
my album would you just do cheers i just
spit a lugia that's just that's
disgusting you are literally vile
whatever all right cowboy tears is out
now everywhere available worldwide dude
if there were every streaming platform
if they were gonna listen to it they
would have done it by now a lot of
people don't know it came out
the greatest album of all time you
should listen to it from top to bottom
the way it was intended the way it was
created from yours truly and our lord
and savior
stop
okay so so
this is bad how how are the reviews on
the album the reviews are in people
loved it really yeah
he gave it a really high grade
did he really yeah he loved it did you
well any that's crazy because
my [ __ ] ad block god damn all right
let's keep moving here that's crazy
because on all music
it got three and a half stars that's
crazy oh it's probably typo
sometimes people will like log in even
the users gave it three stars actually
less than the critics it's okay it's way
ahead of its time it's a classic
i mean have you ever made an album
not in it's not really my thing yeah i
didn't think so it says oh he ripped off
lil ma's x's old town road
that's what it says in the [ __ ]
review but anyway we don't add we don't
we don't need to get too deep into that
does it hurt i'll just ask does it hurt
when you get bad reviews no it doesn't
does it hurt when you get canceled twice
a day it does hurt when i get canceled
does it hurt does it hurt when um
rateyourmusic.com gives you two stars
i've never heard
bro stop
you stop
it's not cool
all right should we just start this
thing over
and let's just no one is going to watch
this episode let's be real all right
where where were we so we watched the
videos you made out with
grandma uh
uh oh this is okay so
this is kind of nuts we're gonna change
the pace a little bit here
my birthday's coming up this month my
birthday's coming up this month are you
june birthday
oh we got we got that to bond on
that's good well guess what what what's
your birthday
june
june
to
25th
no nothing why
[Applause]
so you're actually born four days before
me
you aged horribly
dude it's a band-aid the blood is
seeping through
all right we're both so anyway my mom
within
62 hours
maybe i don't know but my mom bought me
this um
this uh
uh
[ __ ] what's it called
you tell me
whatever 20 oh 23 and me
where they track your ancestry and [ __ ]
and here it is
uh there's
all of it's pretty much expected right
here's my dad my mom my sister my
brother
i actually don't know who sarah davis is
i don't know who that is i guess
probably maybe like uh
distant cousin or something i don't know
barbara
and then i what the f and then i saw
this yeah
olivarius
tree nickel but that's not you because
your name's not all
is my birth name
i just dropped the areas because it's a
little bit long and hard to remember but
yeah it's crazy so
i have a 23andme i did the test last
summer
and
i was looking and about three days ago
i get a notification it says you have a
new relative and i look i'm it says
ethan klein gary klein and donna klein
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this i
thought it was a troll at first and i
looked at it and i was like wait
what yeah are you serious yes
what the [ __ ] it was [ __ ] it says
second cousin twice removed and that's
what michael does what would that mean
that would mean that your mom's cousins
yeah
would be so who so do you know stephen
yeah steven's my uncle
steven's my uncle
so [ __ ] weird i didn't know it was
within though
what the [ __ ]
so that's honestly
it's crazy because people always say we
look alike and they're always like oh my
god i've never seen him in the room at
the same time wait does
so that means ann and jerry are your
grandparents
they're my mom's grandparents okay yeah
that's crazy but the craziest part is
people for like five six years have been
like
ethan
is
the same person as oliver do you ever
get this do people ever call you oliver
they say you're he's like a ethan's like
a better cooler version of all well they
say i'm the handsome version no they
have ethan yeah it's usually like
they say i'm the charming they they go
like they go you know people they go
don't be talented they say incredibly
[ __ ] cool you know how they go don't
be offended but you look a little bit
like oliver tree yeah and i always get
offended because like you are like the
hot version of ethan klein and i'm like
okay there first of all
ethan klein and the word hot should not
be in one sentence well i'm not arguing
with that i'm just saying all right well
that's that's crazy
wait how come i never seen you at the
family reunions
i've been pretty much exiled out but my
mom had a falling out with stephen oh my
god so that's crazy because i heard from
my mom that there was these huge falling
outs in her family yeah and that like
there's certain sides of the family that
don't talk to each other for decades
yeah it's been i think it's been 22
years
so what were second cousins twice
removed
that's insane brother
cousin
cousin don't [ __ ] don't nope
my mind is it's blown right now
shards of glass i mean stop bro
you're [ __ ] like that was a test
i swear to god but for real this is
[ __ ] crazy and honestly it kind of
makes sense
like we're kind of
similar in a lot of ways i don't want to
know that i see myself in you
yeah the d yeah i see myself in you the
demons i'm trying to exercise
through decades of therapy and
antidepressants
all right we're gonna have that's how
you're gonna end that dude that's a big
moment and you're literally just gonna
treat me like [ __ ] again i don't know
what to say i mean it's just
it's a lot to take in well just say this
what you just found yourself the coolest
[ __ ] cousin ever
i don't know i need i need to i need to
like process this a little bit i'm just
saying i'm just i'm i mean at first
the shock is wearing off and now it's
like um
i haven't got to acceptance yet it's
like sadness and anger and stuff like
that
well i'm pumped
and i'm gonna see you at one of these
weddings one of these days didn't you go
to a wedding last weekend yeah my
brother's wedding dude i don't think
stephen's side came no they weren't
invited i wasn't invited but i saw
videos were you dressed up as chewbacca
yeah you saw that yeah that's crazy
i saw it on your mom's account i follow
her okay she's amazing stop following my
mom donna is something else man all
right you want to do this
what
oh an announcement yeah
ladies and gentlemen
i'm so excited to announce first time
ever
i have a new
album
on its way
the deluxe version of cowboy tears
titled
cowboy tears drown the world in a
swimming pool of sorrow
and this thing is a pop punk banger
album that i co-produced with my boy
travis barker
he helped with five of the tricks isn't
that the guy who hosted prices right why
are you working with him oh he's the
dude in blink 182 you might have heard
of him
and
i've got a pop punk album on the way
isn't he dead the guy no
you just married one of the kardashians
oh
is that the new is that how the
album starts
yeah it does
that's fitting
well
i think so i think it's pretty epic
okay what do you want me to do about it
well i wanted to play you can ask your
question
if people didn't buy the normal version
what makes you think they're going to
buy the deluxe version the whole new
album it's a different genre oh really
yeah how is it different wait it's a
whole another album the songs the tracks
are different
you have the old album at the end of it
and the new album at the front of you is
that a deluxe album yeah that's like a
new double album
i made 112 songs i thought cowboy tiers
was your final album it was but this is
the last of it wait how many songs are
you adding i'm adding 12 new songs are
those ones going to be the good ones
these are the good ones okay the thing
is i don't pander to anybody
i made the greatest country album ever
made but now i'm giving the fans a
little bit of what they wanted
some of the classic
pop punk
okay so i'm delivering the fans new body
over yeah
they did okay go ahead do it i wanted to
play you the first song
on
cowboy tears drown the world in a
swimming pool of sorrow and the craziest
part is
it's about you has anyone ever written a
song about you before wait it's oh
really no i don't think so because i
wrote you
a banger
really yeah
okay that's nice and i want to break
down the lyrics
in a segment
for my podcast the greatest podcast in
the world oliver three
what does that mean oh no no no no no no
not that [ __ ]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
greatest podcast of all time oliver
three or as i call it oliver d these
[ __ ] nuts
stop with the music please
this is what your new song sounds like
kind of i do like this
play though honks part yeah
zach i'm about to come over there and
put you in a [ __ ] full nelson you
wouldn't touch that could destroy you do
it [ __ ]
that would [ __ ] [ __ ] dude zach would
bonk you on the head like andre the
giant over there all right get on with
it get on with it bro it's taking too
long [ __ ] you
zach would literally bonk your ass
you want [ __ ]
no i don't you [ __ ] want something
get the [ __ ] down zach get on zach don't
instigate zach come over here [ __ ] it
would have been nice if you came to my
defense when he was headlocking me zach
stop talking [ __ ] dude
what's up
yeah zach
jack sit down oliver is wrong back
wait oliver's running from zach running
from me he's hiding
the [ __ ] is he the [ __ ] out of here
zach
zach no no don't let him go dan let him
go let him get it out
come out of here dude
he's behind the set
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm tired of this goddammit
he's like a rat in the wall
no no no don't go back
it's not safe to be fighting behind the
set it's gonna fall over dude
you hear him he's like a rat yeah
it's like a cockroach
come here you [ __ ] stop zach put him
in his chair so we can get on with it
just grab him and put him in the chair
corner i got i'm coming on the left
i
come right get the [ __ ] off me look
don't hey guys don't [ __ ] around back
there you're gonna knock over the second
come out here you're gonna knock over
the set at once
just
you're gonna [ __ ]
take a seat
oliver no no no no no sit the [ __ ] down
just put him in his back
put him in his chair you can touch me
sit [ __ ] him down
i swear to god bro
i swear stop stop stop chilling sack put
him in his chair no no no zach's right
dan stop stop no no no don't stop zach
put him in his chair put him in the
chair over here guys there's there's sit
down there's broken glass over there
this is just pick up your glasses
outrageous
why would you do that shut up sit the
[ __ ] down
stop chill zach you've gotta see thank
you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
just stop dan no he damn he needed it
stop danny it's chill we're all good all
right chill you chill just let's just
continue all right you want to do this
dumbass song
[Music]
whoa all right
let's do the song i need my tea
i want my voice up
you got something for what you're gonna
say i'm gonna sing
i got f i can coat your throat with
these nuts stop
it's not funny dude i lost his charm
after i did it i don't know i heard love
laughing and he's like the deep nuts
connoisseur that was a [ __ ] good one
bro thank you bro oh we got him so good
high five love
mmm that was a good one oh yeah baby
[ __ ] all right come on we i don't
know about date no we don't have coat
throat bro
this is a podcast not a goddamn
karaoke night
all right so we're gonna do the lyrics
right bobby do you want to come uh
sit in what is it
he's just gonna do the lyrics
for a new song
and there's an empty seat
and i know you hate him as much as me
which is good
actually i feel like i've got an ally
here finally
well i was walking down go hey um ethan
is uh this is where he does his podcast
because i was at that store next door
yeah and then i and then one of your
guys that you know the guy teddy fresh
guys goes come in this guy um oliver
trees is gonna be here oh he recognized
you yeah okay i've done this podcast
before many times yeah yeah and i go
what's an oliver tree right right right
and then he goes i first i thought you
said olive tree you want to see the new
olive olivetree.com yeah olivetree.com i
go is that a clothing line a new one
because no there's a guy he's a
singer-songwriter i come up here and
then all this
things happen and well you came just at
the right time because it was oliver
gets a little he's i don't know he's not
so you're what do you do you're youtuber
[Laughter]
that's a really good question oliver
what do you do
i do everything what does that mean
rock star pop star country star
i do it all
yeah writer you know how it is
crazy is it is that what it is you know
that black pack pack a wack pack yeah
he's a whack oh that's cool yeah i like
this do i have a microphone or something
you're wearing a laptop bro do you know
what you think
yeah i forgot you're like oh i'm a
magician oh what can i get a mic well
there's a lav right here like it's
called a log not a lav you dumbass
i think it can be said either way no i
don't think so never heard get the lab
can i get a mic oh could you get a mic
right here [ __ ] hey were you in an
accident is that a neck brace
that's also a good question bobby [ __ ]
off were you
you
in
an
accident
brace i was in an accident when i put
you guys both in the [ __ ] hospital
we're sitting right here right here i'm
fine when did you were literally crying
give me your band-aid
well you hurt me
yeah you did hurt him okay and i hurt
you too you didn't touch me i took you
both at once play the footage back
let's see an instant replay of me
creaming both of you [ __ ] i
don't we don't have that yeah we don't
have that you guys are literally a
hundred years combined and i took you
guys down hey youtube sing your song he
is a youtuber which is funny and that's
the best part
because i have a bigger following than
both you dumb asses combined
uh that's that's that's debatable yeah
well i certainly have more followers
quality versus quantity well if you not
if you take my original channel i think
i have more so your original channel is
dead it's a ghost town yeah like your
career go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome
to oliver three the greatest podcast in
the world and today i am doing a song
breakdown with genius featured on oliver
tree three the greatest podcast not a
real podcast shut the [ __ ] up dude
this song
is written about someone
that i used to consider a friend
ethan crime ethan crime
how do you say it
[ __ ] you know to say my last name ethan
grimes
how do you say it
i'm not going to see it's ethan climb
right yes yeah
this song is written about a guy
who i used to consider a very close
friend when
ethan
grime at what point did you consider me
a closer would you just shut the [ __ ] up
and let me if you're gonna say if you're
gonna say [ __ ] it better be accurate
stop although this song
is written
for someone who i consider my best
friend ethan grime
i'm dedicating this performance
to a very special lady treat this vocal
performance is for you
but the lyrics are about this [ __ ]
buffoon
okay
so i'm gonna sing this acapella
show you a little taste of the new album
that i've been working on for two years
cowboy tears drowned the world in a
swimming pool of sorrow a little
dramatic don't you think shut the [ __ ]
up let me just do my thing okay tears
you're gonna fill a hole i'm gonna start
singing okay you want to just stop
i
i just stop with the stupid sound
effects
that was [ __ ] awesome perfect dude
that was so good that was [ __ ]
awesome
zig [ __ ]
i need my tea
can you get me the throat coat tea we
offered you she's flaming hot cheetos
mountain dew i want the [ __ ] mountain
dew all right you ready go how's my hair
not good all right what was the name of
the that asian dude who was like william
hong yeah
[Applause]
did it offend you if i said you looked a
little like him bobby
i mean you know
dude don't make me turn on you okay no
no i mean i could side with you no no no
no no i just i'm sorry i'm sorry i just
meant that with all with all the peace
and love in the world
there's just a little bit of resemblance
and not because you're both asian it's
more than that
sick
you [ __ ]
bro i'm sorry i'm all right i made a
mistake coming here let me just i'm
sorry i take it back i take it back i
take it back can i please just go ahead
william hung
all right
[Music]
all right
shut the [ __ ] up and let me do my
performance
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll i'll be good
some things are still stuck inside my
head
some days are still better than the rest
i started like you
less and
it since we made
my life's been a mess
[ __ ] you
are you gonna let me talk you're gonna
play sound effects
i'm trying to put my [ __ ] heart in
this song okay this is the reference to
the first time i ever met you ethan
grime
the first podcast i thought hey
this dude's pretty cool
he's not half bad
but by the end of it
my life started to [ __ ] spiral
that was the beginning of you dangling a
carrot in front of me telling me all
these [ __ ] empty promises promising
the ad revenue 55 45 split in my [ __ ]
favor which i have still not received
the money which you keep doing run
around with my [ __ ] lawyer jeremiah
jeffrey telling me that the money has
been sent but it's stuck in mid transit
i still haven't received the wire i'm
still trying to figure out where the
[ __ ] this went wrong are you even
listening no
listen i'm sorry what
gotta go i was on reddit okay
you you wanna leave no
i just wanna get out of here because you
wanna get away from him it's a little
bit but you want to stay
what do you want to do you don't have to
you can can i continue can you continue
and we'll have a sidebar here because no
i'm trying to see yeah just for the sake
of breaking if you're talking i can't
hit the melody right just could i just
um can you go all over but you need
his record company pays me a lot of
money
i'm trying to tell you what this song is
about okay all right yeah really good
man okay you're the worst best friend i
ever had really good man that's cool i'm
sorry before that happened to you
all i could see
was your stupid [ __ ] face
that ugly [ __ ] mug dude
i couldn't get it i closed my eyes all i
see is your second cousin dude
second [ __ ] cousin yeah you clearly
talking about your own face
missing a chromosome
also last night he was wearing the same
exact thing
that's why he stinks all right can i
continue dude he's home he yeah
you're wearing i'm gonna praise you
and all you do is stab me in the back
so thank you
because now all i can do is laugh
it's about you okay okay
when i came on your podcast you
literally stabbed me in the [ __ ] back
ethan how
you said you'd be nice to me you said
you'd treat me cordial and with respect
and you took my [ __ ] trust and you
turned on me you took the [ __ ] knife
you stabbed me and you turned it
and every time you get canceled i
[ __ ] laugh
those are the greatest moments of my
[ __ ] life when i see ethan
trending on [ __ ] twitter
and i'm like this [ __ ] guy and i
laugh every [ __ ] time
when i first met this guy he i tried to
introduce myself and he wanted to rub
dicks
that's [ __ ] up that's disturbing
you're a [ __ ] pervert dude all of a
sudden i just finished this oliver
didn't you have your hands out and you
wanted to grind oliver caused me
stop
okay oliver epstein
can i continue
just i'm trying to give you a [ __ ]
performance you're talking go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go
you
only like to talk about yourself
do you ever think about anything else
and i really bothered to ask me how i
felt
you're too busy staring in the mirror
and yourself
so those lyrics are about you ethan
take a [ __ ] look in the mirror
take a cold
[ __ ] long stare at what you've become
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
whenever we would hang out you would
just talk about your [ __ ] problems
it's you you you oh
trevor and michael did this today oh my
god tequila is [ __ ] falling apart
their names
every [ __ ] second all the drama oh
gary did this donna did that oh my god
my life's so shitty dude bobby i don't
give a [ __ ] go ahead hold on do you like
arby's i love rvs yeah they have good
curly fries yeah they're really good i
just think i like the sauce
the sausage and the rv sauce and then
the rest of the horseradish one that's
right
they're cheap they're like 99 cents dude
yeah dude guys
jalapeno poppers too can we get harvey
poppers all right i'll check they're
doing a five for ten oh i'll pay you
i'll pay no i'll pay can i just finish
please let's do it i got you i got you
all right you keep that i got you i'm
gonna buy you like 20
yo for
make sure they get the sauces which
sauce i like the rv sauce and the
horseradish sauce
get an order of jalapeno poppers
shut the [ __ ] up man i'm trying to
[ __ ] no this is important hold on
this is important honestly we're so
hungry yeah this is so hungry get me a
band-aid you guys [ __ ] deserve each
other but you guys have diet cokes in
in-house so we have diet or any sodas i
like soda [ __ ] water
no no but we we do need we do need food
so let's just get a ton of arby's
sandwiches a ton of curly fries a ton of
poppers yeah yeah a ton of sauce is
there anything else good on the menu no
that's it yeah but don't don't get the
fancy sandwich there's like the regular
one i don't want the one with the cheese
cheese no no cheese okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll take one of the fancy ones
yeah you want cheese i'll try both yeah
i tried one cheese
the beef beef and cheddar raw okay
oh yeah
i love you i love garlic i love it
wait for the sandwiches to come out you
have to get it now but isn't coke zero
insane how it like tastes just like it's
like
it's like
diet coke is dead
cards yeah okay yeah and just get a
bunch for everybody okay okay
delivery time is 45 minutes yeah that's
all right that's good good good don't
ask me to come over and picture oh
oliver's here sorry go ahead you're not
friends okay go ahead man we're not
[ __ ] friends
okay
when you were born your parents sad
i just feel like they were sad right
usually that's a joyous moment yeah yeah
but they're like like a tear like a
single tear went down and they were just
like shut the [ __ ] up because your face
is like
like that like a dolphin bro is that a
human or a dolphin yeah and they were
like oh we [ __ ] up so that's why you
have a younger brother right that's
probably like did you [ __ ] a dolphin
you know like when a black baby comes
out but it's not even a cute it's a
dolphin yeah yeah yeah
all right go ahead finish go ahead i'd
rather stay here
sluggish
okay go ahead
i would be a much happier person if i
never [ __ ] met your stupid [ __ ]
face mm-hmm
if we could just separate well separate
phrase and just never see each other
wyoming is that enough you move too you
guys should eat two in the middle of the
river
hey hey you guys
all right i'm sorry twelve regular well
you're not doing schtick i actually want
arby's right ethan homecoming yeah i
want arby's yeah i just wanna make sure
he's not you would just move to wyoming
eat healthier so today's the last thing
this is the day honestly let go jupiter
tomorrow we're good okay or even tonight
we're good yeah all right so tonight we
eat healthy but for lunch
ton of horses
and you were not here on this [ __ ]
planet
i would be a much happier person this
would be a much better place than leave
i wasn't even listening yeah shut the
[ __ ] up you're not even part of this
dude this is me and ethan's episode and
you [ __ ] weasel you're waiting here
because you're a [ __ ] clout chaser
what are you doing here i was walking
down the street yeah you just said
you're just yelling come on in can i
have some food
get the [ __ ] out of here yo this is
insane look at this picture [ __ ] seat
wait no this is crazy wait bobby look at
this photo can you guys keep it down i'm
trying to order stop stop look at this
photo i found bobby look on the screen
whoa
[ __ ] pearl dude that's what i said
you're [ __ ] bro get the [ __ ] out of
here [ __ ] you don't call me a [ __ ]
pervert you [ __ ] pervert dude stop
don't
[ __ ] guys
that's all bobby throws kicks dude
bro i swear to
god zach sit the [ __ ] down no thank you
zach
dude do you want me oh wait wait okay
okay i'm gonna make it up to you okay
i'm gonna play that actually are you
giving me arby's i don't want it no i'm
not arby's i didn't order food for you
um bro i'm sorry but this just
do you think it's kind of [ __ ] up that
billy deep put justin bieber in the
thumbnail like that
i mean that's a bit much
it seems a little [ __ ] up
why do you get so much enjoyment out of
people's lives crumbling no no no i'm
not i just no i felt horrible for what
happened to justin bieber that poor guy
he gets the worst health luck man he got
lyme disease and then he got this nerve
thing but do you do you guys think it's
a little wild for philly d to put that
in this thumbnail
i mean it's it's it's big news i know
but the photos but it looks a bit much
i wasn't trying to
i think it's okay he caught like a
particularly
i feel like bad screen cap
that's anyway right i just saw that no i
wanted to play your songs
um i wanted to listen to it so that we
can get the full experience
thank you that'd be great
yeah um have you heard it yet
i just heard you singing it now
so you haven't heard the fully produced
version with autotune
no i haven't i'm really excited to hear
it
i think you're gonna like it
has anyone else written you a song
i don't think so so i have
but you did yeah
for your roast
okay
oh actually love said hundreds of fans
have written me songs lots of fan music
do you know what a fan is
someone who likes what you do
that was funny they laughed dude they
laughed they [ __ ] laughed at that
please don't hit me like i'm serious
i'll [ __ ] you up i just don't like this
threat of violence
i hate you oliver trio
all right well
i basically
want to end this
as soon as possible like that yes and so
we i'm just going to wrap it up we got
you presents because you always bring us
presents
are you serious right now yeah we all
got your face
i swear to god look they they're all
piled over there for you like christmas
morning we all got you presents why all
of a sudden giving me presents after
i've given you at least what
40 dozen presents every time i came on
the show and not a single gift except
for that stupid [ __ ] wagon you always
try to give me
well
to be honest with you uh we wanted to
return the favor not that you honestly
you got them great gifts i never got
[ __ ] i gave you great gifts remember
when i gave you that [ __ ] ring yeah
great i'm sure yeah we had to delete it
because it got us age restricted nice i
thought it was cool hila loved it i
think it was a caulk cage actually yeah
that's true
okay well um
olivia do you want to come help bring
the packages over
cool
wait wait can i olivia can i do the
gifts instead yeah let treat do the
gifts i prefer if olivia does i prefer
if treat does it
all right grandma okay grandma i'm good
grandma bringing presents out okay
that's kind of nice
turning into the grammar show
all right
jesus
all right so why don't you just bring
one over i don't know who's that from
what does it say
from zach oh from zach this one's from
zach thank you so much
all right we can't do this every time
again there's a lot of presents if we
could yeah maybe
would you shut the [ __ ] up now yeah
let's let's let him open it oh whoever
told dan to just shut the [ __ ] up
not stop i refuse oliver real quick you
got me a fantastic gift last year which
i still have on my desk i'm sorry last
episode yeah you know i have it on my
desk so i wanted to return the favorite
song let's not forget the mayonnaise i
got you about just open it just open the
[ __ ] gift
let's open it i mean not that anyone's
counting but is that minecraft wrapping
paper we got your favorite video game
no are you [ __ ] kidding me yes dude
so i got that for you so you could comb
out your dingleberries from your ass
wait did you seriously just give him
knives that's [ __ ] next to me
no it's a uh
you really just gave him oh it's a
butterfly comb ow
so actually that is kind of a dope gift
badass thank you but it's for your
dingleberries all right i'll use it for
my pubes for sure honestly this is a
really cool prop for you yeah those are
for me you know get get your crabs out
it's it's good it's a good gift for you
thank you man this is incredible i'm
honestly honored that is actually this
is really [ __ ] dope thank you thank
you
all right a nice gift from zach
stop stop
i like it a lot
okay the next one is is that mine no
it's too oliver from abe and lina okay
abian lena my favorite
proud of ab after everything he's
accomplished in the boxing world even if
that was an extremely unfair fight the
guy was 20 pounds heavier i mean it was
[ __ ]
thank you you can do mine last i just
want to say i i picked this out though i
do want credit for picking this up you
picked this out yeah lena didn't have
time
no [ __ ] way
holy
oh my show it i did it uh no no no it's
if i did it if i if it's oh yeah it's
really small there and
in the eye you can barely see it but
it's called if i did it
right there an eye mostly it says i did
it this is yours truly yeah do you know
the story behind that book what's this
oj simpson wrote this [ __ ] book about
how he killed
his wife
who would the woman he was acquitted for
right and this [ __ ] was going to
publish this book to turn a coin [ __ ]
you bro i swear to god
i'm trying to educate people yeah okay
and he don't aren't you shocked that he
wrote a book called if i did it about
how he killed his wife and then the
uh
the parents of the lady he killed sued
him and won wow and so they own the
rights to this book and that's why the
if is so tiny and impossible to read i
love that so basically they i'm sorry to
touch your gift but please don't they
made if i it just looks like it says i
did it because the goldbergs published
it and they got all the money from the
book so kind of an epic own there thank
you so much jb that's an incredible but
unfortunately i do not read so but why
did you get this one about a murderer i
thought he likes like you know crime
mysteries and i thought
this one is what's greater than one
that's real
you're not trying to say anything are
you no i love it
someone gave him a knife and the other
person gave him a book about a guy who
cut his wife's head off i mean
your pieces are good what are we getting
at what i had next president please
thank you
sorry to oliver from dan this one's from
dan oh that's from me which one of you
was dan that's me um oh with the guy
with the funny chair yeah yeah so last
time the president that you got me you
had done a deep dive on my social media
to find out that i like gumby and you
got me all this great don't like it you
love it yeah i loved it i loved it but i
gave you some dvds some different types
of yeah it was the whole series on dvd
and it was also a little key chain yeah
exactly i've given you some other great
gifts over the years though
yeah and so i really felt like i needed
to reciprocate here so i did a deep dive
on you and found out what you're a big
fan of and i think you're gonna like no
[ __ ] way are you [ __ ] kidding me
what do we get
it's literally my favorite
it's the dark magician girl from oh i
know what it is of course you know the
dark magician girl from what from yugioh
is that some lowly you've never played
yu-gi-oh it's literally my favorite game
is that one of the ones where like
there's like women who look like they're
eight but they're of age so you can do
you're a [ __ ]
that's a badass gift right there thank
you sir you're so welcome i'm gonna put
that up right at my manager's house
excellent
i'm glad you like that's incredible
this one's from cam
hello
what's happening
okay
thank you
who is this from this is from me i know
you uh
wait i thought is this from cam yeah
it's me i honestly didn't even know you
knew who i was dude i love you man stop
dude i love you so much dude i love you
too cam so let me just give you a little
little synopsis of this gift it's uh
something i know you appreciate is that
next to you cameron i'm sorry who's that
sitting next to you uh what's your name
again well
it's high pitched paul
shout out to high pitched paul in the
building and shout out guys
[Applause]
paul's the real celeb laker are you a
lakers fan high pitch paul no a shock i
got this from shaq it's jack's shirt
that shirt is literally shaq's shirt his
dj career
he got it from one of his talk about dj
diesel it says lakers on it though
so you're a fan of shaq's dj career not
of
lakers paul you're an amazing guy but uh
i was in the the
i mean it's kind of cam's moment
all right so yeah i know you like this a
lot you got the same gift for myself
for lena and sam the last time you're
here so i hope you enjoy it i know it
means a lot to you
wow so this isn't that special of a gift
you're just giving it to everybody dude
i know you love it okay no he's saying
it's because it's a similar gift to the
one that you got for cam last time that
you were here incredibly
no [ __ ] way no way it's an amazon box
yeah look what's inside
there's literally nothing yeah exactly
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you at least i wrapped
it this time go [ __ ] yourself dude
no one told me you were going to be here
dude the best crew don't we folks
we do
you want to get you again that's almost
as good as i did it
don't touch o.j simpson
okay no bring in the next gift keep it
coming
wow
can you guys like chill
should we open this one together yeah
i'd like that what the oh olivia can you
do something about your grandma i've
given up this one's from ian apparently
shout out ian
okay guys just keep it pg here yeah
treat okay
it's not really great for the shot to
have you in there dan shut the [ __ ] up
dan
zip it no dan is right
it's just a little awkward with with
both of you and then get the shot at
that spot so there you go let's not move
closer to me okay let's not listen no no
i'm not in this throttle it's a tree
it's a tree stop stop
it's a tree ways actually we'll be
opening this one for me
yeah nice and slow
fast
did you guys like disgusting
i think what is wrong with you tree my
god
there's something there is something
wrong with this with your grandma olivia
olivia isn't she getting picked up at
some point your mom coming where's your
grandpa olivia
dead
oh my god grandma's right damn right and
get are you a black widow or you're
going to end up dead next
they're watching stop because you just
couldn't keep up with me if you know
what i mean
you heard it here first folks
all right can you can you unwrap that
faster would you shut the [ __ ] up dude
we're taking our time
[Music]
hey
hey grandma do you know what minecraft
is
i do
okay great wow
you see that that's crazy this is that
time that i was with kanye west and kid
cudi
whoa wait i didn't realize you were
oliver was in this photo hey oh you
photoshopped it i've got a little
announcement bro guess what happened
since this picture was taken and since
our last meeting ian
your boy
was at [ __ ] kid cuddy's house
making music with him shout out scott
cuddy hates kanye legend why would that
be cool can we get a close-up on this
shot doesn't kick cuddy hates on you we
got kanye
kid cuddy
yours truly and then of course over
yonder
yep that's me
that's a dope picture you weren't there
you're familiar though did you just
re-gift me my gift or what yeah well
that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold on hold on oliver gave that to me
last time yeah i did and
it was sweet but i don't want it
you've disavowed your kanye roots right
yeah but
i have a i have a
special surprise an extra
bonus if dan can bring it up yeah
wait
there's more to this gift no way this is
the kanye
scroll subreddit and on the right no
[ __ ] way how did you land that razor
stop stop stop
is that your real life
[ __ ] are you serious five hours ago he
got you out dude are you [ __ ] kidding
me dude you gotta go
can you zoom in dan so we can just see
right on the holy sh
there it is there it is no way round of
applause one more time check out that uh
though incredible
oh wow
you got an ad in there wait there's a
boy tears is a light three what the [ __ ]
bro
hey [ __ ] off that's a flare on reddit
that's what they call it that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right i don't want anything
but you're a mod you're modeled kanye
that's pretty cool all right thank you
they
they said
you can't have any
permission to do anything i'll do what i
want but
no permissions you have no permissions
you have no power to be determined it's
actually you know it's a technical not
really next gift honorary uh position
what do we have here who's this from
olivia
olivia
seems to have gotten you a
what
is that a live fish oh my god it's a
real [ __ ] fish yeah bro be careful
wait is that alive
it's not just any fish it is
what is that insane it's a [ __ ] beta
fish
[Music]
oh don't worry i have the proper
rectangular tank and everything
that is so [ __ ] epic and i want to
say this
you're literally the only reason i was
tuning in to the h3 podcast oh and as
soon as you went back to school i
literally stopped watching and now i
have a reason to watch again so that is
awesome thank you by the way you this is
the betta fish that's right rocks
for real did you see what i named the
fish on the little card what does it say
yeah it's a real fish in there man
it says
wow this is olive from olivia to oliver
right right playing words well thank you
so much olivia that's crazy a betta fish
you identify with that fish
oh i'm gonna go that far
i've got alpha and i have an alpha fish
at home i have an alpha fish never be a
beta
amazing all right what do we have next
wow we have so many gifts my goodness
stop wow disgusting
i'm so what's disgusting this whole
[ __ ] show and dance you guys are
doing
i mean with peace and love and god
and we haven't danced
today
whatever bro
do you take like grandma viagra
like what's wrong with bro chill the
[ __ ] out you look jealous
i just i don't know i've just it's just
a lot
[Music]
like the ground it's turning into like
the grandma show just chill out more
than you can handle maybe
oh my god
morbius my favorite movie
[Applause]
whoa whoa whoa
oh
there's a live fish here don't you care
about animals
you almost killed that live fish
hey
no
morbius
don't touch it just come on keep going
you know oliver i wasn't really sure
what to get you but um you didn't give
me anything last time either so i
thought this would be better than
nothing
that is way better than nothing for
those who don't know
it's my favorite movie of all time and
would you stop with the sound effects
way more than you this is an
embarrassment of riches
all right what do we have here oh uh i
believe that one's from love actually oh
[ __ ] yeah i love that yeah yeah it must
have uh like dropped off and shipping
from sweden
uh yeah no he doesn't need help with it
stop okay sit down
sit the [ __ ] down grandma tired of your
old ass her name is treat okay it's not
grandma
someone used salt instead of sugar in
that treat holy [ __ ] no [ __ ] way
careful there jesus christ dude
what is that that's my favorite band
ever
yep gorilla i knew that
[ __ ] yeah and you see the signature
stop wait who paid for that
shut them up wait how much was that oh
a lot i i went there and personally got
it signed and everything wait what how
much where did you go
hold on before you ask too many
questions there's a yeah here let me see
it real quick
yeah thank you yep
wait dad is dan a gorillaz fan
no no no
sit back down oliver [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't know what's happening dan ran off
with it
over you might remember
the gift you gave me yeah it was an
incredible back
you took it back i gave you an ipad with
an app in it no this is important
[ __ ] took it back a digital
girlfriend for you to fall in love with
where is it i didn't promise you the
ipad no i promised you the app that i
didn't know either
you didn't leave me either can we burn
that book please don't touch the book
bring it back so that's a real wow
that's probably bringing it back right
here probably really valuable love both
girlfriend back
i'm
keeping her in his basement or something
weird i know how demented that
[ __ ]
so
bring her back yeah you gave love a
virtual girlfriend but you took back the
tablet
yeah because that wasn't part of the
gift the gift was that i had designed an
app for love to have a digital
girlfriend not that he was going to get
sounds
all right
dude i'm not made of money okay one more
come on okay bro i want i want that gift
back if you want if you bring the
girlfriend i want you you'll get back
now that's the deal okay
girlfriend plus ipad oh yeah no no no no
no we're gonna destroy the book
no we're not yes bring the book back no
i want my girlfriend back i will hold
you around you can have her i built you
an app bring the last gift this one's
for me
this is thank you grandma this is the
last one it's from ethan from me ethan
cries and trust me this one is heartfelt
as it gets i mean it really comes from
the heart
i mean that truly and utterly
this is the most genuine thing i've
probably ever done for you
and uh i think it can be and it's
actually i think it can be really useful
for you oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now
this is literally incredible so
for those of you who can't read
this is music composition for dummies
and this is actually the book that i
used to have and i don't own it anymore
but this is the book that got me started
this is how i learned how to write songs
this is how i've made multiple platinum
hits this is how my album ugly is
beautiful read it again went gold the
entire album went gold um and this is
based on music composition for dummies
there you have it this is where i
learned everything
read it again
i'm going to read it a few more times
and for those of you who don't know this
book changed my life and it can change
yours all with the simple 6.99
didn't really pay a lot is that how much
it is yeah well that's cheap
you're a cheap bastard so i'm not read
it again though this book's great though
that's crazy you actually read that yeah
because i listen your music it doesn't
sound like it
that's crazy you actually read that book
that's nuts
well thank you man that's honestly an
epic sounds like some it's stop because
when i listen to me it sounds like a
gorilla just smashed his head against
him
go down easy go down easy
all right all right you know what
guys don't touch my [ __ ] hair
you [ __ ] dick
you know what
i'm sick
i'm [ __ ] done with this [ __ ] guy
yo you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i'm tired of this [ __ ]
i'm tired of living afraid of you i'm
[ __ ] tired of you i'm tired of you
always getting violent
let's just settle this
how
shut up [ __ ] and follow me
what
just follow him
we got a little something prepared
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[ __ ] nuts
advice advice let's go ethan that's your
advice let's go
[Music]
your right is the sucker punch man wait
which is the left then the left of the
jab man
yeah yeah
okay let's do our team championship
why don't you shut the [ __ ] up hold me
back right now hold me back hold me the
[ __ ] back grandma don't tell her to shut
up yeah [ __ ] up yeah
you're a christian nobody yeah crusty
ass old vagina
don't talk about her hey jesus
don't say that about my grandma yeah
don't say about her [ __ ] grandma dude
you're a [ __ ] prick all right here's
what we're gonna do
hundred thousand dollars to the winner a
charity of their choice you don't even
have a hundred thousand dollars yes i do
i'm gonna end your youtube channel once
and for all you stupid [ __ ] dumbass
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
let's go let's go let's go
oh
[Applause]
gotta get him good
any water no mercy no murphy the [ __ ] is
that a sweat towel
no don't drink anything all right try
this one
who drink it
take the [ __ ] cap off what the [ __ ]
are you doing
[ __ ] you
the straw's broken [ __ ] damn what the
[ __ ] why would you shut the [ __ ] toss
who did that get him a straw get in
there we need to know
their hands is the other hand hits in my
ass [ __ ]
that's right gotta [ __ ] it's
friday it's friday yeah thank you thank
you that's what i needed to hear all
right let's go dude you gotta use all
your strength all your might okay okay
sacrifices got out should i piss in
oliver's ass
why not can you do some of the pumping
he's telling you smash the important
work i'm working here
he's falling apart out there
thank you
that's such a
that's the sweet spot
yo i want a massage what the hell hey
have one of your little cronies give you
a massage bro
why do you think i picked her from my
team i'll massage if you want yeah yeah
would you
thanks oh bobby's got me
thanks man this means a lot faster dude
i mean i'll show you how it goes
all right all right here we go
round two wait wait i'm not ready
oh
no way
[Laughter]
you use this as a [ __ ]
axe
all right eat the luck ethan try the
slime look at him he's sweating like a
little [ __ ] stuff here
there you go guys
i can't make it you gotta cut me right
so i'm gonna cut you up no cut my face
okay okay i can throw it okay okay dude
dude you're obviously [ __ ] awesome
i know you're cut we gotta go to the
hospital but check it out okay your
gloves are [ __ ] okay yeah so we have
to go to drastic measures okay all right
bare knuckles do with the korean way
holy [ __ ] you want me to put him over
there with him yes crack him get your
glass in the tide his eyes
don't find him no no
i'm going to stab him to death huh sure
we're going to kill him right
yeah should i kill him
my gloves are [ __ ] ruined dude
[Music]
right there
all right round three here we go in
three two one
thanks for watching
oh
it's over
that's for feeding domestic terrorists
america
that's what you said
stop breathing
stop breathing
wake up
ethan let me take care of this is he
okay i don't think so
oh wait he's convulsing he's convulsing
now call an ambulance yeah call the
ambulance he's he's not good maybe he's
just crying
uh
no he's having a seizure get him some
slime yeah he's having a seizure
get him the red slime
i i don't think the slime where's your
slime
i don't know if the slime is gonna get
him some slime somebody calling an
ambulance
okay all right olivia's on it
[Music]
try some of this
there you go
here you go little buddy chase that down
with a little slime there you go
it seems to be making him convulsion
more you're okay you're okay you just
need a little slime
okay no seriously call it let's call the
ambulance
they're coming
oh my god eat him he's dead
you gotta wake up man
[Music]
the ambulance is on the way but um
you win
really yeah you won
bring it in girls
you need to check for a hundred thousand
dollars oh my
god oh my god
i'm gonna get this
this is a big moment
i'm gonna dedicate this to the albany
foundation
never heard of that
what the before
did you just say
no please leave games okay
[Music]
getting your flag
[Music]
i did this in my country
i will not let a domestic terrorist like
ethan clyde walk another [ __ ] day
[Music]
[Music]
god bless america
secretary's country is the world
hell
yeah all right well uh the ambulance is
on the way right
olivia yeah daniels is on the way
all right well um
let's i mean they can take care of this
let's let's shut it down
turn the lights off yeah they said
they'll be here
all right we'll just leave the door open
for them it's fine you good ethan
all right all right let's go everybody
let's go everybody out there
all right everybody out
let's go
everybody out
tree
yeah i know i know
yeah wow that looks spicy um
we're shutting down so
just
find your way out of here thank you
all right
hey uh bobby
yeah uh we're we're leaving yeah it's
like tetris yeah i'd see that
we're shutting down you can you can play
in the parking lot but we're locking up
i got blocked out
i know i'm sorry i i'm a gamer too i get
it but
we're shutting down so
be good
make your way down what happened
uh ethan's not doing so hot but there's
an ambulance on the way so it's all good
thanks for coming though
i i regret it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]